boom-boom-boom-boom-boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sake on I'm really excited to
talk about this topic it's extremely
important for us to all embody and have
conversation with each other about it's
about transhumanism and it's about how
we're not quite ready for transhumanism
and I have a bunch of notes I have to
unpack with you all and I'm really
looking forward to it because let's jump
into it and unpack so first definition
transhumanism International
philosophical movement that advocates
for the transformation of the human
condition by developing and making
widely available sophisticated
technologies to greatly enhance human
intellect and physiology yes amazing
sounds great
everyone wants that everyone wants to
greatly enhance human intellect and
physiology definitely and that's what's
been happening over time with evolution
we're not lagging behind we're just
having a nuanced conversation here now
here's where it gets interesting
transhumanist thinkers study the
potential benefits and dangers of
emerging technology that could overcome
fundamental human limitations as well as
the ethical limitations of using such
technologies most common transhumance
thesis is that human beings may
eventually be able to transform
themselves into different beings with
the ability so greatly expanded from the
current condition to merit the label of
post human beings all right let's unpack
this ethical quandary that we find
ourselves in the reason why this is so
important is because of the ethics of
transhumanism and the ethics of what's
going on around us there's still greed
and corruption at play in every single
one of our political and economic
systems I don't think there is one
economic or political system that
doesn't haven't at least a tiny bit of
greed or corruption in it and so it
requires us to expand our souls and
expand our levels of consciousness to a
fully-integrated level of coherence and
resonance with each other prior to being
able to
say I'm gonna go ahead and plug a neural
link into my head and I'm just gonna let
anyone with any greed or corrupt
tendencies control my mind does this
make sense now do we see where this is
going because we don't have consensus on
nuclear weaponry on robots and drones as
weaponry on neural warfare on bio
warfare we have no global consensus on
any of this stuff we're a bunch of kids
we're like a bunch of fifth graders that
are at recess and someone gives a gun
there's a box of guns to the kids and
says you guys should figure out the
ethics are you [ __ ] kidding me we
need to slow down we need to think there
is no reason at all to be going at such
lightning speed that we caused another
arms race which seems to be inevitable
but it's not we have the power we have
the ability to control what goes on in
our world it's now more than ever
important for us to control our urge for
jumping into the maximal technology as
soon as possible
beating China beating the Middle East
beating Russia beating the US beating
your up beating everyone that's so dumb
it's going to cost civilization to
become extinct like every single other
one of the advanced civilizations before
us did because people got too greedy
they got too corrupt every single one of
these massive empires collapsed because
they got too greedy
they got too corrupt it can't happen -
it can't keep happening we have to stop
and find peace amongst each other and
find peace amongst these exponential
technologies that are going to be making
us transhumanist soon so that we can
best solve the ethical dilemmas along
the way through these transfer -
quandary that we face this is a
major deal because we are all men ting
the human ability to think the human
physiology your biometrics are already
being monitored you already have a
smartphone that's monitoring your
biometrics your data is the most
valuable commodity that you have in your
atencion atencion and data and if you
really think about all the sensors that
are in the devices that are monitoring
everything that you're doing already
that that data is you're already being
manipulated so my we're all being
manipulated already by algorithms people
are hacking into our minds already and
this is never before happened in
civilization that they can measure our
data hack into our minds and even
furthermore now it's way easier because
of things that give us even closer and
faster connections directly to the
nervous system of the human being this
is a really freaking important one um
one of our friends his name is Bernard
Gunther he wrote a very great post here
he wrote about transhumanism the
consciousness trap and here he writes
about how transhumanism is extremely
interesting but it's also extremely able
to manipulate who we are and what we
care about if you think about the amount
of negativity that's happening on the
planet still greed and corruption that
that greed and corruption will seep into
the souls of the people that are most
vulnerable so I can make myself most
vulnerable to I can be an open portal
for negativity to come into my soul like
somebody controlling my thoughts and
feelings and emotions and data and
everything and then they can make me do
whatever they want me to do and it's
gonna be some dark energy and some dark
forces that are pushing for this
glee as possible because the more that
you push fast the less ethical
regulations that can come and we all
know that the less ethical regulations
that go into something over time the
less ethicist less philosophers that
work with AI scientists and that work
with bioethicists that the less we will
figure out how to optimally advance and
we will have unnecessary suffering
unnecessary suffering because of the
greed and the corruptions trying to push
into our souls as quickly as possible to
transhumanist movement without us
slowing down to best understand how to
do it quick shout out are we in a
computer simulation are dope t-shirts if
you guys like these t-shirts you can
pick them up on simulation series calm
go share it with your friends over the
holidays ask each other these stop
provoking questions so seriously what
the [ __ ] why are we letting rich there
are some people that are rich and
amazing there are also people that are
rich and greedy and corrupt and wanting
your soul to be an open portal for them
to be able to control because then they
can control their families they can
control your cousin's they control your
friends and control your co-workers and
just be and Bernard writes about this
very interestingly because he takes this
a kind of a step further cuz he talks
about right here he talks about negative
aliens and satanic forces Bernards a
very interesting human being and he has
worked his muscle of tapping into what's
exist past the 3d reality a lot and it I
go to veil of reality calm the links in
the bio go and check this out yourselves
and go and read up more about this and
talk to your friends more about slowing
down geopolitically about transhumanism
to have the proper ethical guidelines
and moral frameworks going forward
that's why there's so many AI safety and
security researchers right now because
they're trying to figure out how to work
together that's why Elon Musk has been
telling the entire world over the last
couple of years you
slow down on a I work together don't
have killer robots and killer drones
geez we drop bombs on the we've got
bombs dropped on us at Pearl Harbor we
drop bombs on Hiroshima Nagasaki that is
effed up and it's only going to get
worse with the sniping technologies that
exist with robotic and drone and
nanotech and bio warfare and neural
Warfare's this is some serious stuff we
have to slow down and think this is not
fear-mongering whatsoever this is
foresight I've had the opportunity to
sit down with so many brilliant diverse
leaders over this last year on our show
and over and over and over again these
different bright diverse brilliant
leaders in their fields at the
forefronts of their fields say the same
thing slow down and think work together
find out the ethics don't rush because
rushing it is what the greedy and
corrupt and want to happen so that we
can be controlled as quickly as possible
and just keep checking keep keep
checking this out because it goes it
goes into further into further fields of
of of contrarian thinking that
definitely needs to happen because when
you take a look at this you see a
contrarian thinker like Bernard that's
talking about the AI and transhumanist
agenda that you know here he's talking
about you know Elon Musk a neural link
and that is again is like you know how
do you trust that the person that has
control of the neural link or the neural
dust or whatever it ends up being that
enables other people to connect us to
Wikipedia but at the same time be able
to upload whatever download whatever
thoughts into our head at the same time
as we can upload that that chew a
communication stream is going to be
benevolent how can you trust that it's
going to be benevolent you have to trust
the benevolent dictator that leads that
company in order to in order to think
that the transition to transhumanism is
going to be
that benevolent and easy and I and I
hope we can get to the ethics together
on time for this because I have I have a
lot of faith in humanity I have a lot of
optimism in humanity but I also am very
realistic about what's going on around
us because I study civilization and
civilization design all the time and the
optimization of civil Asia's
civilization design if you want to
optimize the way society can be built
and constructed you need to slow down
and think rushing causes extra suffering
rushing causes extra suffering man
alright so I just I see so many
geopolitical pressures going on across
our world and it's just ridiculous how
many geopolitical pressures are going on
I mean it's like absurd how many arms
races we have for the different emerging
technologies and we have to figure out
how to just slow down in the practice of
things like meditation equanimity self
work we're looking at yourself
objectively in a mirror body work
spirituality psychedelics these
different practices bring people closer
together and they bring you closer to
source or to God or to consciousness or
to whatever all that is is in in order
to get there you have to work hard on
yourself on sincere self work and
sincere collective work and sincere
collective work with economic and
political and geopolitical pressures
we'll get to coherence with nature
slowly over time so if you trying to
ascribe an age of maturity to
civilization what would it be like ask
yourself this question right here that I
just highlighted you know if you were to
ascribe an age of maturity to
civilization what would it be
because I already gave you an example
were a bunch of fifth graders on a
playground on recess
where someone just gave us a box of guns
and said figure it out because if you're
spiritually advanced enough you will
figure out a way to have everyone
collaborate on getting rid of the guns
and you will be like we're just gonna
continue being our blissful selves on
this playground but the moment that
someone picks up one of those guns and
says that I now own all of the guns and
you all have to work for me and you all
have to be slaves that's the classic
game of Monopoly one person ends up with
everything everyone else ends up with
zero gotta get away from that mentality
to be able to progress as a civilization
we won't be able to make the strategic
leaps and bounds we need in technology
and interstellar colonization if we
can't find peace within ourselves and
amongst each other I love my
transhumanist friends you just need to
slow down a bit I love my contrarian
friends keep propagating this message
and also respect the transhumanists
because they have some long-term visions
that we need to fulfill as well but
we'll do it's more slowly together find
the nuance in this conversation we're
not ready for transhumanism yet but we
will be soon we have to slow down and
think think about it who will teach
robots ethics who will teach a AI efex
who will teach humans ethics we don't
even have our own ethical guidelines
properly formulated
we can do better and I love you all and
I'm happy that you're tuning in for the
show thank you for doing so let's
prevent the bad actors let's prevent the
greed and corruption from entering
through the neural warfare systems that
are going to be made through the bio
warfare systems that are going to be
made through the systems that are
already made through the smartphones and
through the computers that we have
because when you look at this machine it
actually already has some of those
attention economics built into it to
reel you in like a fish with
notifications over and over again reel
you in as a fish with notifications over
and over again because they make money
every single time that you land on their
pages ads ads feed feed feed it's all
cognitive easing because it's an all and
echo-chamber it's not you don't have to
add new perspectives and try and
formulate new ways of thinking think
about it really think about it talk
about it in nuanced with your friends
and start inspiring other people to slow
down and think I love you all thank you
for tuning in give us your thoughts in
the comments below we'd love to hear
from you
join the public telegram let's continue
the conversation there are the links
below go check up an Argand there's work
again the links in the bio below and
much love everyone and we will see you
soon and keep building the future keep
manifesting your destiny into the world
everyone practiced that sincere self
work that meditation psychedelics body
work love compassion coherence of
resonance planetary architecture for
maximal prosperity I love you I love you
and I'll see you soon peace